tout est orchestré à la minute près
décollage atterrissage
à l'aéroport international de genève le
vol lx 28 05 pour zurich s'apprête à
embarquer ses passagers mais une petite
musique se fait entendre
ce n'est pas un air de fête juste une
façon de tenir l'angoissent à distance
ce qui se joue là
c'est une séance de thérapie pour lutter
contre le stress
[Musique]
pour ce petit groupe prendre l'avion est
un cauchemar bravo à toi et où
s'échouent en avions déjà tu vois un
rouge à croix blanche
oui la dernière fois où brigitte est
monté dans un avion remonte à 25 ans
elle est ce que l'on appelle une phobie
qu elle participe à un stage
baptisé s'envoler sans s'affoler ce vol
genève zurich va duré 35 minutes
brigitte va tenter de surmonter sa peur
en compagnie de 15 autres phobique
le groupe s'installe avant l'arrivée des
autres passagers
le décollage est imminent
demandez à l'envers les nerfs sont à vif
julien plus moyen de reculer
c'est ce qui va nous permettre
les statistiques le prouvent
l'avion est le moyen de transport le
plus sûr pourtant un français sur cinq
en auraient peur mais il ya bien
d'autres craintes que les phobiques
emporte dans leurs valises celle de
l'eau de la foule
du vide ou encore des petites bêtes et
c'est un dieu grec qui serait la cause
de leurs tourments phobos était le fils
dares le dieu de la guerre
il incarnait la peur selon la mythologie
phobos accompagné son père au combat à
sa vue même les combattants les plus
aguerris
pris de panique fuyaient le champ de
bataille pour celui qui a le courage
d'affronter aujourd'hui le phobos du 21e
siècle un long combat l'attend
douloureux parfois onéreux mais souvent
victorieux ça fait là
[Musique]
brigitte est une montagnarde une
savoyarde l'altitude ne la gêne pas tant
qu'elles gardent les pieds sur terre
enfermé dans une carlingue c'est autre
chose
lorsqu'elle voyage elle choisit le train
ou la voiture quitte à y passer des
heures
[Musique]
nous avons fait sa connaissance sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport de genève en
compagnie d'autres angoissé de l'avion
elle entame trois jours d'immersion dans
le monde de l'aéronautique
fabienne l'organisatrice de ce stage va
les guides j'expire profondément ça
c'est le plus important
jusqu'à ce que la sensation de vertige
et complètement disparu fabienne regard
sait de quoi elle parle
la peur de l'avion l'a empêché de
devenir diplomate
c'est un stage qui l'a aidé à guérir
elle en fait aujourd'hui son gagne pain
donc la petite exercice consiste à
avancer en prenant donc à chaque fois 1
6 h sur deux comme ça
[Musique]
ok prendre conscience de ses peurs c'est
un premier pas même si cela va
nécessiter un peu de temps pour parvenir
à les dominer je suis quand même un peu
un peu et me suis dit de retourner dans
un avion comme ça tu regardes et j'avais
un peu oublié que quand même c'est assez
serré notamment en économie
fabienne a créé ces stages avec la
compagnie nationale helvétique qui
mettent à sa disposition l'un de ses
pilotes
première étape faire découvrir l'envers
du décor pour apprivoiser l'oiseau de
métal enclenché larroyer j'enclenche les
pompes à essence elles deviennent verte
miracle de la technologie ça marche
oui en fait en principe la philosophie
chez airbus
c'est la philosophie black cockpit d'un
coq si tous les boutons sont éteints
c'est bon signe
la visite se poursuit le pilote invite
ses élèves à se rapprocher de la
carlingue
l'appareil impressionne même au sol vous
pouvez toucher vous n'hésitez pas et
vous remarqué que en fait la
construction du moteur
c'est vraiment tout simple durant ce
stage démonstration technique exercices
pratiques s'enchaînent le train
d'atterrissage rentrer dedans et ensuite
un taux qui se refaire donc vous voyez
de nouveaux sais pas c'est pas une
allumette
c'est quand même quelque chose de
costaud de solides brigitte et ses
camarades enregistre une foule de
données mais comprendre le manuel de vol
d'un airbus a320 ne suffit pas à
rassurer un phobique fabia nous prend le
relais alors je pense âge note au
tableau pour chacun alors brigitte quand
on déconne alors on va commencer par le
décollage donc décollage après
maintenant ce que j'aime pas ça des
turbulences mais c'est l'impression de
tomber alors tu plus ok ensuite autre
chose hong électronique dans la bonne
électronique total continue les oiseaux
dans le réacteur ou bien aussi les
oiseaux
idée reçue fausses croyances
superstition c'est au tour du pilote de
briser les mythes qui nourrissent les
peurs bas les turbulences c'est pas
dangereux en l'air vous avez le vent qui
crée en fait des vagues qu'on ne voit
pas mais qui sont quand même là donc ya
pas de vide le vide n'existe pas il n'y
a jamais un avion qui s'écrasait à cause
des turbulences jamais
mais l'actualité récente court circuite
les explications rationnelles du pilote
dans la tête des participants résonnent
les dernières catastrophes aériennes
comme celle de la compagnie german wings
germanwings donc alors ou non maintenant
on n'a plus le droit d'être seul en
effet lorsqu'il ya un des pilotes qui va
aux toilettes
il ya une personnel de cabine qui vient
à ce moment là dans le cockpit tout à
fait
personnellement moi je préfère que ça
soit un problème un problème
psychologique etc avec un pilote plutôt
qu'un problème technique sur un airbus
a320 que j'ai piloté aussi pendant des
années
crash de l'airbus de la german wings
disparition de l'appareil de la
malaysian airlines accident du vol
rio-paris d'air france en 2009
chaque drame aérien ravive les angoisses
trois jours de stage sont ils suffisants
pour guérir définitivement de sa phobie
parmi les participants certains
reviennent pour la seconde fois c'est le
cas de yves c'est un bon départ c'est un
bon coup de main de vitamines mais ce
qui est essentiel
après c'est de reprendre l'avion très
très souvent qu autrement ça les ans et
vivant parce que le sol s'était bien
passé mais après j'ai pas exercer du
coup la peur est revenu aussi vite
qu'ils avaient disparu depuis 2014
fabienne a enregistré une hausse de 30 %
des demandes de stage son carnet de bord
affiche complet des mois al avance dans
son arsenal de remède antistress
on trouve aussi des séance de
calinothérapie à l'heure du dîner
fabienne regard s'est entouré de
bénévoles d'anciens phobique qui passe
aujourd'hui une partie de leur vie dans
les nuages
en fait on va jeu se connaître avec les
coupes devenu anges gardiens pour
angoissé de l'avion chacun déploie ses
ailes au dessus d'un nouveau venu mais
non on va la rive on ne te fais pas de
souci tu n'es pas tout seul tu n'es pas
tout seul cela fait sept ans que
philippe est guéri aujourd'hui il
partage son expérience je pense que ce
stage il est fait comme sur le principe
des alcooliques anonymes
y'a pas mieux pour parler de la
bouteille sur lui que celui qui a bu il
n'y a pas mieux pour parler de peur en
avion que celui qui a eu peur en avion
qui en est libéré qui respire c'est
génial
stéphane sera aux côtés de brigitte
durant son vol ensemble ils passent en
revue leur check list à quelques heures
du décollage
[Musique]
la respiration
comment tu vas vraiment demain à manger
à d'être demain la fouille a les seins
il n'y a plus d'autres c'est tout
il est 6 heures du matin j'aime bien
j'ai bien j'aime les turbulences lever
aux aurores brigitte optent pour la
méthode coué
ses camarades eux n'en mène pas large
le moral est en chute libre
[Musique]
petit à petit face aux gens
en route pour cette expédition digne
d'une mission spatiale
brigitte tente de mémoriser les derniers
conseils pour prendre comme tel il faut
surtout pas anticipé faux carnets en
tout être dans le présent constamment
constamment
[Musique]
merci le décollage est un moment
difficile
une fois dans les airs
l'attention va se relâcher petit à petit
[Musique]
l'omble tellement non blindée continue
c'était tellement d'émotion qu'il
fallait que ça sorte
ça fait 25 ans il fallait que ça sorte
un amant cieux que d'émotions c'est un
truc de 300 livres
atta
j'ai un grand bonheur la libre pas
complètement encore mais j'ai un grand
bonheur je son culot et demi c'est
soi-même
awek est en fait l'avion et n'est jamais
sûr du monde si on arrive à se faire du
mal et d'âge fille je suis plein de joie
pour elle parce que je pense que c'est
vraiment le début d'une nouvelle fille
katia s'apaisent
[Musique]
et paula a transformé le coin des
hôtesses de l'air en salons de danse
on arrive on arrive à commencer un petit
peu l'atterrissage sur l'aéroport de
zurich est presque une formalité
les 35 minutes de vol sont passées très
vite ces trois jours de stage coûtent
950 euros par personne selon fabienne
regard
le taux de réussite serait de 98% la
compagnie suisse n'est pas la seule en
europe à proposer ce service
air france le fait également 640 euros
pour une journée mais s'envole et
désormais c'est tout un marché qui se
développe autour de cette peur de
l'avion séances de psychothérapie par
téléphone à 100 euros la pelle exercices
de relaxation sur smartphone plongez
dans un simulateur de vol
on trouve de tout à tous les prix
je vérifie que la poussée des collages
des amis bien passé aussi le point
commun de ces différentes formules la
promesse d'une guérison rapide mais qui
n'est pas toujours au rendez vous si la
peur fait vendre
domestiquer ses émotions est une affaire
de temps
régine a grandi en alsace entre cigognes
et vignobles à l'heure de la retraite
elle migre vers la côte d'azur
cap sur la méditerranée pourtant elle se
méfie de la grande bleue
elle est aquaphobes la plage de saint
cyr sur mer attire de nombreux touristes
mais régine elle ne prend jamais de bain
lorsqu'elle se risque près des vagues
l'eau lui donne des sueurs froides
enfant elle a failli se noyer
ce traumatisme est devenue une phobie
elle lui semble insurmontable
elle le vit comme un handicap
[Musique]
dis à quelqu'un quand je ne sais pas
d'âge et que j'ai peur de l'eau on
allait en devenir mais comment commencer
comme si je disais je ne sais pas faire
du vélo vivre en bord de mer sans en
profiter pleinement
cela fait 50 ans que régine emporte dans
son sac de plage sa phobie
elle a décidé de se faire violence et
s'est inscrite à des cours particuliers
d'aquaphobie et des bas cette nuit je
suis un peu j'ai pas première rencontre
avec son coach bonjour et bienvenue
voilà de découvrir le bassin où vous
allez essayer d'évoluer premier tête à
tête aquatique la piscine peu profondes
et privés aucun baigneur au but ne pas
se faire remarquer me moquer
régine a besoin de calme et d'intimité
pour surmonter sa phobie tu restes en
douceur le premier 25 cm en chine
pascal loustanau est un ancien joueur de
water polo retiré de la compétition il
s'est reconverti dans le traitement de
la cua phobie première étape mettre son
visage sous l'eau allez je plie les
genoux je respire et je bascule
[Rires]
vingt minutes plus tard
régine arrive à maintenir son visage
dans l'eau
voilà on se détend et bien voilà c'est
le passage de la verticale à l'horizon
bascule en avant très important
15 % des français seraient aquaphobes
une phobie généralement liés à des
souvenirs d'enfance une noyade évité de
justesse un maître nageur autoritaires
ou des parents eux-mêmes craintif de
l'eau il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
peur de l'eau et on ne les connaît pas
malheureusement pas s'il se dévoile pas
l'encré c'est ça surtout ni pascal
facture ses services
60 euros de l'heure pour un phobique
l'investissement est souvent à la mesure
de cette erreur mais le visage dans
l'eau milieu aller laisse les salles
étaient jean blaise a été gentil mais ça
me paraît très long que moi je me dis ça
va être très long en quelques séances
régine en a conscience son cocon d'eau
chaude n'a rien à voir avec l'immensité
salé et agité de l'océan un ancien
aquaphobes peut-il un jour se sentir
comme un poisson dans l'eau
réponse à 7000 kilomètres de là à vol
d'oiseau ou à 9 heures d'avion
nous voici en martinique sur la plage de
sainte-anne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je fasse que je veux je peux je fais ce
que je veux 1 et c'est parti
les vacances aux antilles ça n'est pas
de tout repos pour ce groupe de lyonnais
eux aussi sont aquaphobes mais en voie
de guérison
ils ont vaincu leur peur au fond de la
piscine municipale de villeurbanne et ce
séjour en bord de mer s'annonce comme
une renaissance pour daniel trois ans de
luttes auront été nécessaires avant de
pouvoir envisager des bains de mer la
profondeur ça y est
et là c'est une vraiment impatient de
repartir vraiment à 0 0
sur par trois essais avant ton est même
pas pu rentrer annonce qu'on a faim mais
cela va la tuer donc tu repars à zéro
c'est un bélier qui entraîne tout ce
petit monde dans son sillage
c'est le souffle à la tête d'une
association
cet ancien prof de sport a suivi pas à
pas les progrès de chacun de ces
baigneurs cette immersion dans la mer
des antilles c'est le dernier stade de
la thérapie il fait beau on est on est
dans l'eau est chaude et ça facilite
vraiment le travail s'arrête plus pour
les personnes
ce stage coûte 3000 euros par personne
pour deux semaines
[Applaudissements]
alain leur réserve une dernière épreuve
à la fin du séjour
un baptême de plongée
on ne parle pas d'une baignade avec
masque et tuba mais d'une vraie plongée
avec combinaisons et bouteilles sur le
dos un défi pour daniel prendre du
plaisir à regarder à me détendre
sachant que je serai accompagné et puis
après ben voilà doit repartir un petit
peu tout seul même si je n'ai pas pierre
quoi le bruit parce qu'il est fait pour
marcher dans les 5 mètres sous la quille
du bateau mais soudain les aquaphobes
semble bel et bien libérés de leurs
peurs
c'est encore plus beau que ce que je
pensais été ramassés du simple ça fait
une drôle d'impression je n'ai pas de
chiffre magique en salles cet été daniel
a prévu un séjour à la montagne mais
peut-être un jour et changera-t-elle
l'ivresse des cimes contre celle des
profondeurs pour d'autres la phobie ne
prend jamais le large
la vie à la campagne pour marlène n'a
rien de séduisant
une peur incontrôlable a tissé sa toile
autour de la jeune fille elle est
arachnophobes
[Musique]
allez là y'avait aller là dans la maison
familiale
sa mère pourchasse toute espèce
d'araignée jusqu'aux plus petits
spécimens
voilà la monstre cette délicate
demoiselle s'était invitée au déjeuner
crise de panique en vue pour marlène
depuis l'adolescence dès qu'elle se
retrouve face à huit pattes velues
elle craque guava monte monte monte
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de solution au
final quoi ça quand quelqu'un va finir
par arriver mais mais ça peut être très
longue mais j'arrive et d'attendre une
heure trois quarts d'heure à pleurer et
à trembler ça va vraiment assez loin il
a fallu un certain temps à ses parents
avant de comprendre qu'il s'agissait
d'une phobie soir elle nous appelle
parce qu'elle ne peut plus bouger talab
une araignée donc les a décoincés faucon
viennent à tuer l'enlever les premières
fois serait que je me disais elle fait
du cinéma on prend un peu sur toi écrase
là on sera pas tout le temps là tout
l'art et prennent acte des brouilles
avec une arrive une peur obsessionnelle
[Musique]
ah oui qui oblige marlène a ponctué son
quotidien de rituels envahissons je vais
fermer ma porte ici
et puis je vais je vais prendre un le
traversin comme ça et si la nuit jeudi
voilà les situations comme ça je vais
juste faire au plus vite comme ça je me
dis au pire sur la une et je la vois pas
c'est pas grave puisque la ville sera
fermé que je sais qu'elle peut pas
rentrer là c'est pas possible qu'elles
rendent donc je préfère pas la voir
comme ça j'ai pas peur
soutenue par ses proches marlène s'est
résolu à consulter une psychologue
celle ci lui propose une thérapie
comportementale et cognitive méthode
couramment utilisés pour soigner les
phobies le principe est simple exposé
très progressivement le patient à
l'objet de ces peurs
démonstration alors je commence par une
photo d'une araignée sur donc
certainement une partie des gros sentais
prête il y a quelques semaines
elle en était capable c'est le principe
du vaccin oms one
en gros le mal par le mal dans le sens
où on va exposer l'organisme à la
situation qui fait peur pour atteindre
ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon une
habituation c'est à dire que l'organisme
havas détendre va se rendre compte qu'il
n'est pas en danger
et du coup va baisser les symptômes de
peur cette thérapie exige beaucoup de
persévérance et une bonne mutuelle
une vingtaine de séances sont en moyenne
nécessaire le prix varie entre 30 et 140
euros de l'heure selon la qualification
du thérapeute loin des solutions
proposées par la médecine
il existe des alternatives qui peuvent
aussi des livres et des peurs à 400 km
de lyon la jeune fille va tester l'une
d'entre elles nous voici à paris la
capitale abrite un endroit hors du temps
un lieu peuplé de créatures rares
marlène a rendez vous avec celle que
l'on surnomme madame araignée
ça va
[Musique]
christine rollard et biologiste au
muséum national d'histoire naturelle
c'est une spécialiste reconnue des
araignées à titre bénévole
elle reçoit dans son laboratoire les
arachnophobes pour l'aider sensibiliser
mais encore faut-il pouvoir franchir le
seuil
alors tu vas à ton rythme tut
imprègne tranquillement d'accord parce
que vraiment dans une pièce
effectivement araignée
face à l'impressionnante collection
marlène est en état de choc
c'est pas grave c'était ne suis pas les
yeux ça va aller ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup hein mais tu es toujours prête
à me fait d'accord donc à la volonté
vais faire ça c'est très bien le plus
dur est presque fait marlène se
rapproche de sa phobie patiemment
christine va détailler le mode de vie de
l'araignée expliquer son importance dans
la nature et dans nos maisons
je vais te juge est injuste en est une
et ça ça correspond à une petite mine
galles intègre honnête tu prends ton
temps donc celle ci tu sais qu'elles
vivent dans une sauce est en soi dans
ces mignons quand même des méga la
chaussette qui vivent dans une sauce est
en soi au grand désespoir de la
biologiste l'araignée et la paria du
règne animal elle suscita version et
peur chez bon nombre de français et a de
plus en plus de monde et je ne peux pas
le dire non à des gens qui viennent en
dix ans mais j'ai peur je suis pas bien
dans ma vie quotidienne
qu'est-ce que je peux faire qui je vais
voir elle propose alors à marlène de
manipuler avec une pince à épiler un
spécimens conservés dans l'alcool super
vas-y samson trois gardiens
à rennes c'est très bien et maintenant
tu tu ouvres aller n'a fait aller dit tu
n'as fait ici les placards débordent
d'exercices pratiques
c'est là mais je suis toujours là c'est
encore une mule ok elle est toujours
morte
le temps s'écoule voilà et marlène se
montre bien audacieuse en train de
caresser une mule a pas d'accord à
travers cette approche naturaliste la
jeune fille progresse dans sa bataille
jusqu'à accepter de partager son espace
vital avec une araignée vivante elle
descend on vous descend le long de son
fils elle se déplace sur ma main ok
d'accord c'est ça que tu regarde plutôt
que je regarde elle va pas sur toi là
non non non je reste bien oui je fais
gaffe nas est la dernière étape je te
dis donc il faut que tu la vois se
déplacer il faut que tu la regardes il
faut que tu te dis elle va pas vers moi
et cette approche au fur et à mesure il
reste encore du chemin avant que marlène
et l'araignée ne se découvrent des
atomes crochus
se frotter à l'objet de sa frayeur est
donc un passage obligé si l'on veut
guérir
on peut y arriver de manière détournée
[Musique]
près de marseille dans les bouches du
rhône des chercheurs ont eu l'idée
d'emmener leurs patients dans une autre
dimension sur les traces des thérapies
anglo saxon la réalité virtuelle est
devenue leur outil de travail en
compagnie d'un psychiatre marie est prêt
à expérimenter la thérapie 2.0 dans un
univers de films de science fiction
donc on place le transmetteur qui nous
permet de transmettre des informations
du rythme cardiaque aux ordinateurs de
l'installation des électrodes pour la
surveillance cardiaques dans un endroit
s'il vous plaît des capteurs qui vont
enregistrer ses mouvements marie son
problème c'est la crau phobie la peur du
vide grimper dans un téléphérique ou en
haut d'un monument très peu pour elle
[Musique]
dans quelques instants ce cube va
s'animer
quel est votre niveau d'anxiété de 0 à
100 à
la commencer de suite comme ça l'est
vous êtes un peu anxieuse abrité
derrière des lunettes en 3d
elle se retrouve projeté de manière
virtuelle dans une piscine sur un
plongeoir
vous pouvez commencer à marcher sur
cette planche en bois au dessus de la
piscine comme dans un jeu vidéo
marie se déplace dans ce décor à l'aide
d'un joystick à son rythme et en dosant
le degré de difficulté
est ce que voulait refaire la même chose
ou est ce qu on fait un boulot difficile
toujours ici j'ai passé voilà si on
pouvait essayer d'accord très bien
soudain l'eau disparaît la sensation du
vide et donc du vertige s'accentue marie
est virtuellement perché à 10 mètres de
hauteur à l'écart les chercheurs notent
l'évolution de son anxiété
insolite cette méthode ne serait guère
différente d'une thérapie
comportementale classique
les scientifiques observent que plus le
cerveau de marie est exposé à la peur
plus ils s'y habitue cette dernière ne
se rendraient plus compte qu'elle n'est
pas dans la vraie vie
excellent mari très beau travail et fait
partie du réel
on m'a fait je vis du réel était très
dure pas juste un même corps j'ai la
chair de poule g 8 femmes pour moi c'est
une vraie situation après 8 10 sessions
de thérapie en reste et virtuel vers les
patients se comporte de la même façon
dans la réalité et donc on conserver
leurs acquis et peuvent ainsi avoir
moins peur dans les situations bien
réelle cette cyber thérapie semble
prometteuse et des sociétés privées s'y
intéresse elle met au point des
visiocasque qui seront commercialisés
dans un futur proche pour environ 400
euros
simple anxieux ouvrait phobique chacun
pourra s'exercer
l'intérêt dans les phobies c'est qu'ils
pourront non pas seulement s'entraîner à
l'hôpital avec le psychiatre le médecin
ou psychologues mais qui pourront
continuer leur thérapie chez eux avec
leur propre casque
le dieu phobos aurait-il trouvé plus
fort que lui en ce 21ème siècle avant de
boucler notre valise pour une pause au
soleil
nous avons reçu des nouvelles de ceux
qui ont osé affronter leurs peurs régis
terreau parti en avion vers nice régimes
profitent de la piscine de ses voisins
et marlène voit ce éclaircir l'horizon
de ses vacances au camping
[Musique]